pour gérard vespière analyste
géopolitique et chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
joe biden devra s'atteler à travailler
sur quatre points clés vis-à-vis de
l'iran écoutez le je crois que la
position de joe biden elle est en quatre
chapitres a premièrement il faut se
préparer à résoudre cette question que
l'on appelle la somme cette clause qui
est à dire actuellement à partir de 2025
il n'y a absolument rien de prévu
le fameux jcp aux as devient cadeau
qu'il faut préparer le futur
après 2025 mais c'est bientôt on est
presque en 2021 déjà donc premier
chapitre la presse
jcp aux as deuxièmement il y a
effectivement le retour à des iraniens
dans le cadre de ce cet accord
techniquement donc en termes de
d'enrichissement abc l'enrichissement à
baisser les stocks d'uranium et ses
troisièmement il ya le programme des
missiles qui ne sont pas pour voir
partie de l'accord du jcp aux as mais
que là en général les pays occidentaux
veulent voir aborder et quatrièmement il
y à l'intervention iranienne avec le
hezbollah au liban en syrie où les
milices iraniennes sont présence on
parle pas de l'irak parce que là la
présence iranien effectivement est très
importante et puis aussi l' influence de
l'iran au yémen